zoe curious why you wrote a story about
a 40-year-old
actress who's struggling for work in
hollywood
um well it doesn't seem like a very um
unusual story no you know i
am i think for me personally
writing is parts of my life and parts of
my life so i
although this movie doesn't exactly
pertain to the person that i am
it definitely has feelings of who
i am or what this age brings to me and
what i'm noticing about myself and about
others
and so i thought hollywood was a really
interesting metaphor
place to like set a stage because it's
so about
this kind of outside look and what you
look like and how thin you are and how
perfect you can be and this
this striving for perfection that's so
um i know it scares me a little bit
because it's not really who i am i like
the kind of
messy parts of life and so i thought
this would be a really good way of
describing
what it's like to have all those
pressures on you as a
as a 40 year woman and if you before you
completely accept that you
are past a certain age you're still
fighting for that youthful
moment and how do you find that balance
and
make it serve you the best way right
and it reminds me of the documentary
searching for deborah winger
where there were various hollywood
actresses interviewed about
you know getting older in the industry
and i think they talked about that gray
area where
once you're like what 35 to maybe 50ish
there's very few roles that you can play
maybe once you're past
that 50 mark there's more sort of
grandmother or
maternal type roles what's your
experience been with that in terms of
casting for your own films and talking
to other actresses
about that gray area that this film
seems to be about
well you know i don't think we're
ever aware of our age until we're that
age and then it all becomes all too
you know there um
i think about you know it's funny i
think about my mom and
my mom had some of her best roles ever
in her whole life or anyone's life in
her 40s and her 50s and
it's because my dad saw something in her
that was a very vital woman that had
there was a certain understanding of the
complexities of
when you get older and a woman over 40
because we're full of all kinds of
interesting things that you know maybe
we weren't
10 or 20 years ago so yeah
i talk about it a lot with different
actresses
because i'm interested i'm interested in
writing parts for
i mean i'm not just specifically
interested in writing parts for women
but i like writing parts women because
i'm a woman and i see what they go
through and i
it's an interesting exploration so
so um yeah i think everybody's very
concerned i think that there is like a
building consciousness about it that
people
men and women alike are starting to feel
the imbalance of it
and starting to if not fight for at
least wish
for some movies about you know these
women in
these ages
you